you're now ready to see how to go one
layer of a convolution on your network
let's go through the example you've seen
in the previous video how to take a 3d
volume and convolve it with say two
different filters in order to get in
this example two different 4x4 outputs
so let's say convolving with the first
filter gives this first 4x4 output and
convolving with this second filter gives
a different 4x4 output the final thing
to turn this into a convolutional neural
net layer is that for each of these
we're going to add it bias so this is
going to be a real number and what -
broadcasting you kind of had the same
number - every you know one of these
sixteen elements and then apply a
non-linearity which for illustration
that says there a luna mini arity and
this gives you a 4x4 output after
applying the bias and the non-linearity
and then for this thing at the bottom as
well you had some different buyers again
this is a real number so you had the
same row number - all 16 numbers and
then applies some non-linearity that
fairly non-linearity and this gives you
a different 4x4 output then same as we
did before if you take this and stack it
up as follows so they end up with a 4 by
4 by 2 output then this computation
where you've gone from 6 by 6 by 3 to a
4 by 4 by 4 this is one layer of a
convolutional neural network
Center mapped is back to one layer of
for propagation in the standard neural
network when a non convolutional neural
network remember that one step afford
prot was something like this right
z1 equals w1 times a0 a0 was also equal
to X right and then plus b1 and he
applied the non-linearity to get a 1 so
that's G of Z 1 so this input here in
this analogy this is a 0 or this is
actually and these filters here this
plays a role similar to w1 and you
remember during the convolution
operation you're taking these 27 numbers
or really well 27 times 2 because you
have two filters repeating all of these
numbers and multiplying them so you're
really computing a linear function to
get this 4 by 4 matrix so that 4 by 4
matrix the outputs of the convolution
operation that plays a role similar to
w1 times a0 is really maybe the output
of this 4 by 4 as well as that 4 by 4
and then the other thing you do is add
the bias so this thing here before
applying value this plays a role similar
to Z and then let's find me by applying
the non-linearity you know it's kind of
this I guess so this output right plays
a row this really becomes your
activation at the next layer so this is
how you go from a zero to a one
disperse the linear operation and then
the convolution has all these
multiplying so the convolution is really
applying the linear operation and you
had the biases and the apply Rayleigh
operation and you've gone from a six by
six by three dimensional a zero through
one layer of a neural network to I guess
a four by four by two dimensional eight
one six plus
three has gone to four by four by two
and so that's one layer of a
convolutional net now in this example we
had two filters so we had you know two
features of you all which is why we
wound up with an output four by four by
two but here for example we instead had
ten filters instead of two then we had
wound up with a four by four by 10
dimensional output volume because we'd
be taking ten of these maps not just two
of them and stacking them up to form a
four by four by ten output volume and
that's what a one would be so to make
sure you understand this let's go
through and exercise let's suppose you
have ten filters not just two filters
that are three by three by three and one
layer of a new network how many
parameters does this layer have well
let's figure this out each filter is a
three by three by three volume so V by
three by three so each filter has 27
parameters right since 27 numbers to be
learned over and then plus the bias so
that was the B parameter so this gives
you 28 parameters and then if you
imagine that on the previous slide you
know we had drawn two filters but now if
you imagine that you actually have ten
of these right one to ten of these then
altogether you would have 28 times 10 so
that would be 280 parameters notice one
nice thing about this is that no matter
how big the input images the input image
could be 1000 by 1000 or 5000 by 5,000
but the number of parameters you have
still remains fixed as 280 and you can
use these ten filters to detect features
you know vertical edges horizontal edges
maybe other features anywhere even in a
very very large image we're
just a very small number of parameters
so this is really one property of
convolutional neural nets that makes
them less prone to overfitting that you
could so once you learn ten feature
detectors that work you could apply this
even to very large images and the number
of parameters also remains fixed and
relatively small as 280 in this example
so to wrap up this video let's just
summarize the notation we're going to
use to describe one layer to describe a
convolutional layer in convolutional
neural network so layer L is a
convolutional layer I'm going to use F
superscript square bracket L to denote
the filter size so previously we've been
saying the filters are F by F and now
this superscript square bracket L just
to knows that this is a filter size is a
F by F filter in layer L and as usual
the super-sick square bracket L is the
notation we're using to refer to a
particular layer L going to use PL to
denote the amount of having and again
the amount of padding can also be
specified just by saying that you want a
valid convolution which means no padding
or a same convolution which means the
accused of having so that the output
size has the same height and width as
the input size and then we're going to
use SL to denote destryed now the input
to this layer is going to be some
dimension it's going to be some n by n
by number of channels in the previous
layer now I'm going to modify this
notational bit I really use superscript
L minus 1 is because that's the
activation from the previous layer L
minus 1 times and C of L minus 1 and in
case Apple so far we've been just using
images with the same height and width
but in case the height and width might
differ I'm going to use
superscript H and superscript W to
denote the height and width of the
from the previous layer alright so in
layer L the size of the volume will be
NH by NW by NC with superscript 0 square
bracket no it's just that in layer L the
input to this layer is what have you had
from the previous layer so that's what
you have L minus 1 there and then the
new network excuse me this layer and
then just layer the new network will
output will itself output the volume so
that will be an H of L by n WL I and C
of L that will be the size in the output
evening and so whereas where previously
said that the output volume size or at
least the height and width is given by
this formula
you know n plus 2p minus F over s plus 1
and then take the floor of that or round
it down and in this new notation what we
have is that the output volume delvia in
layer L is going to be the dimension
from the previous layer plus the padding
we're using in this layer L minus the
filter size we're using this layer L and
so on and technically this is true for
the height right so the heights of the
output volume is given by this and you
can compute it with this formula on the
right and the same is true for the width
as well so we cross out 8 and 4 and W as
well then you know the same formula with
either the height or the width plugged
in or up for computing the height or
width of the output volume so that's how
an HL minus 1 relates the image Ellen
and WL minds one relates to n WL now how
about the number of channels where the
dose that was come from let's take a
look
if the output volume has this death well
we know from the previous examples that
that's equal to the number of filters we
have in that layer right so we had two
filters the output volume was four by
four by two was two-dimensional and if
you had ten filters then the output
volume was four by four by 10 so this
the number of channels in the output
volume that's just the number of filters
were using in this layer of the new
network mix how about the size of each
filter well each filter is going to be
FL by FL by one of the number right so
what is this last number well we saw
that you need to convey six by six by
three image with a three by three by
three filter and so the number of
channels in your filter must match the
number of channels in your input so this
number should match that number right
which is why each filter is going to be
FL by FL by n see L minus 1 and the
output of this layer after applying the
biases and the non-linearity is going to
be the activations of this layer al and
that we've already seen will be this
dimension right the al will be a 3d
volume as NH L by MW L by M C help and
when you are using a vectorized
implementation or your battery and
ascend or mini battery in descent then
you actually output AO which is set of M
activations if you have M examples so
that will be M by n HL by n WL by n CL
right if say using batch gradient
descent and in the program emphasizes
this would be the dimension this will be
ordering of the variables and we have
the index and the training examples
first and then you know these three
variables
NIC's how about the weights or the
parameters or kind of the W parameter
well we've already what the filter
dimension is so the filters are going to
be FL by FL by NC or minus 1 but that's
the dimension of one filter
how many filters we have well this is a
toner on filters so the weights really
all of the filters put together we'll
have to mention given by this a times
the total number of filters because this
last quantity is the number of filters
in there l and then finally you have the
bias parameters and you have one bias
parameter one real number for each
filter so you're going to have you know
the bias will have this many variables
it's just a vector of this dimension
although later on we'll see that in the
code will be more convenient represented
as a 1 by 1 by 1 by NC o-- dimensional
your four dimensional matrix were four
dimensional tensor so I know there was a
lot of notation and this is the
convention are used for the most part as
I mentioned in case you search online
and look at open source code there isn't
a completely Universal convention
standard convention about the ordering
of height width and channel so if you
look on source code on github or read
some of the open source implementations
you find that some authors use this
order instead when you first put the
channel first and you sometimes see that
ordering other variables and in fact in
some programming frameworks as in
multiple common frameworks is actually a
variable or a parameter but you want to
list the number of channels first or
list a number of channels loss when
indexing into these volumes and I think
both of these conventions work ok so
laws are consistent and then and
unfortunately maybe this isn't and
unfortunately maybe this is
one piece of notation where there isn't
consensus in the deep learning
literature but I'm going to use this
convention for these videos where we
list you know height and then width and
then the number of channels lost so I
know there was suddenly a lot of new
notation to introduce but you're
thinking well this long notation how do
I need to remember all of these don't
worry about it you don't need to
remember all of this notation and
through this week's exercises you become
more familiar with at that time but the
key point I hope you take away from this
video is just how one layer of a
convolutional neural network works and
the computations involved in taking the
activations of one layer and mapping
that to the activations of the next
layer and NYX now that you know how one
layer of the convolutional neural
network works let's stack a bunch of
these together to actually form a deeper
convolutional neural network that's
going through the next videos